انتقل بكم مباشره الان الى العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس وهذه الصور المباشره
لاستمرار الاحتجاجات ضد اصلاح قانون
التقاعد في فرنسا ورفع سن التقاعد من 62
الى 64 عاما معنا من هناك فرد دهوك فادي
انقل لنا الصوره من عندك نرى سيارات
مكافحه الشغب الفرنسيه عندك في الشارع
اهلا صهيب خرج خرج التظاهره في هذه
المنطقه
التجاريه في وسط باريس كما ترون الشرطه
حصلت المتظاهرين وهي الان تقوم بمرافقتهم
او تقسيمهم الى مجموعات وتاخذهم الى محطات
المترو لكي تؤمن خروجهم من هذه المنطقه
وتضمن عدم اعاده تجمعهم او لقائهم مع
اصدقائهم الذين قاموا
بتفريقهم طبعا في بدايه هذه التظاهره التي
خرجت بشكل عفوي ولكنه الشرطه بسرعه
يعني انه تفريقهم الى مجموعات صغيره على
ما نشاهد يا فادي يعني ليس تفريقا عنيفا
نعم صهيب هم الان يفرقونهم بشكل سلمي لكن
في بدايه التظاهره جاءت الشرطه واطلقت
الغاز المسيل للدموع حتى تمكنت من محاصره
هذه المجموعات كل مجموعه حصلتها في زاويه
هذه الشوارع هنا في هذه المنطقه ضيقه جدا
فتمكنت الشرطه من محاصرتهم عبر مجموعات
صغيره كل مجموعه كانت في شارع وايضا حصلت
حالات اعتقال هناك على الاقل حتى الان ست
حالات اعتقال بحسب ما صرحت وزاره الداخليه
الان يقومون بمرافقتهم على عبر محطات
المترو ليخرجونهم من هذه المنطقه وهذه
التظاهرات هي مستمره وتخرج بشكل عشوائي
والشارع الفرنسي ملتهب منذ فتره طويله يا
فادي لنشرح قليلا للمشاهد العربي البعيد
قليلا عن الشان الفرنسي ما الذي حصل وما
الذي زاد في غضب هذا الشارع مع استخدام
الرئيس الفرنسي لماده في الدستور تخوله
اقرار الاصلاح في قانون التقاعد بدون
الذهاب الى البرنامج
نعم صهيب هذه التظاهرات اندلعت يوم الخميس
الماضي وهي مستمره منذ ذلك اليوم بسبب
قيام الحكومه بتمرير مشروع رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما من دون المرور عبر البرلمان
وتصويت النواب عليه الان هناك مذكرات لسحب
الثقه من الحكومه سيبدا التصويت عليها
ابتداء من جلسه البرلمان يوم غد الاثنين
وهذه المذكرات تحظى بدعم من قوه اقصى
اليمين بزعامه مارين لوبين وايضا من قوه
اليسار هذه المذكرات حتى الان يسعى النواب
لكي يستميل عدد من نواب الحزب الجمهوري
الذين هم غير راضيين عن هذا القانون وايضا
من المحتمل ان يصوت عليه ان كان لدي الوقت
ايضا صهيب كان هناك اخبار او هناك صور
نشرت لعدد من المقر والمكاتب التي تتبع
لنواب حزب الرئيس وايضا لرئيس الحزب
الجمهوري اريكسيوتي تمت مهاجمه هذه
المكاتب وكتب عليها شعارات مناهضه لقانون
رفع سن التقاعد لان هؤلاء النواب هم
داعمين لهذا القانون وكان هناك ادانا من
قبل وزير الداخليه طبعا هناك تاهب ابني
كبير جدا في العاصمه في محيط المقر
الحكوميه وايضا لحمايه النواب الذين
يؤيدون هذا القانون بحسب ما بحسب برقيه
ارسلها وزير الداخليه جيرالدرمانه الى
مؤسسات ومديريات الامن العامه في معظم
المدن الفرنسيه نعم فادي ساكتفي معك بهذا
القدر الان يعني تبعنا معك هذه الصوره
الحيه لتفريق هذه المظاهرات المستمره
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد على الاقل ما
شاهدناه يعني الشرطه تبتسم للمتظاهرين هي
نجحت على ما يبدو في تفريقهم سلميا يعني
وتقسيمهم الى مجموعات صغيره كما تابعنا مع
هذه الاستراتيجيه التي انتهجتها الشرطه
الفرنسيه شكرا لك فادي على هذه الصوره
الحيه مباشره من باريس